[Music]
It is the best-selling book in history.
No volume ever written has been more
loved and quoted. And its words,
sometimes simple and sometimes
mysterious, should always be studied
carefully. It is the Bible, the word of
God. Welcome to Bible Answers Live,
providing accurate and practical answers
to all your Bible questions.
This broadcast is a previously recorded
episode. To receive any of the Bible
resources mentioned in this broadcast,
call 800-835-6747.
Once again, that's 800-835-6747.
Now, here's your host from Amazing Facts
International, Pastor Shawn Ross. Hello,
friends. Welcome to Bible Answers Live.
Pastor Doug is out this evening, but
this is a live, interactive,
international Bible study. So, if you
have a Bible-related question, we would
love to hear from you tonight. The
number to call is 800-463-7297.
That is our phone line here to the
studio. Again, that's 800-463-7297.
But, before we get to the Bible
questions, let's begin with an amazing
fact. On August 24th, 1875, Matthew Webb
slipped into the water at Dover,
England, and 21 hours and 45 minutes
later touched land in France, becoming
the first person to conquer the English
Channel.
Swimming the English Channel became one
of the greatest swimming challenges of
the day.
Since Webb's triumph, more than 470
people have been successful in swimming
the English Channel,
including a 12-year-old boy in 1979
and a 12-year-old girl in 1983.
The first woman to swim the English
Channel was a 19-year-old American
Gertrude Ederle.
On the 6th of August, 1926,
she crossed the English Channel in 14
hours and 31 minutes. That's 2 hours
faster than the men's record, setting a
woman's record that stood for the next
35 years.
Then came Alison Streeter, known as the
queen of the channel.
She has swum the the channel more times
than anyone else, 43 crossings to date.
Streeter first swam the channel at 18,
and was the first woman to swim the
double, that is from England to France
and then back to England.
And it's the only only woman ever to
have completed the three-way, that's
from England to France, back to England,
and then to France again.
But, possibly the greatest triumph of
endurance is held by Benoît Lecomte,
who, with the aid of two French sailors
and a 40-ft sailboat, swam, believe it
or not, across the Atlantic Ocean.
On the 16th of July, 1998, he set out
from Cape Cod with eight wetsuits, a
snorkel, and some
and some flippers,
navigated through the 40th and the 50th
latitude, and protected by electronic
force field, Lecomte swam 6 to 8 hours a
day over more than 3,000 nautical miles
of relentless waves.
72 days later, on the 28th of September,
he swam ashore, exhausted but heroic, in
France.
Now, did you know, friends, that the
Bible teaches that at the end of time,
Christians will also need to have a high
degree of endurance? Not so much
physical endurance, but more
importantly, spiritual endurance.
You see, the Bible tells us in Matthew
chapter 24, verse 11,
it says at the end of time, many false
prophets will rise up and deceive many.
And because lawlessness will abound, the
love of many will grow cold.
But, he that endures to the end shall be
saved.
To be a Christian in the last days
requires endurance.
The reason for this endurance is because
Revelation chapter 12, verse 17, talking
of God's people at the end of time,
says, "And the dragon," that's Satan,
"was enraged with the woman," that's the
church,
"and he went to make war with the rest
of the remnant of her offspring, who
keep the commandments of God and have
the testimony of Jesus." So, at the end
of time, the devil is enraged with the
church, the true church, the remnant
church, and he's making war with those
who are keeping God's commandments and
have the testimony and the faith of
Jesus. Well, friends, we want to be
amongst those that have spiritual
endurance in the last days. How can we
now prepare for what is yet to come?
Well, one of the ways that we can
prepare prepare is by filling our minds
with the word of God. The word of God is
our sure strength and our protection.
Our free offer today is a book written
by Pastor Doug entitled The Ultimate
Resource, and it's free. We'll send it
to anyone in North America. All you have
to do is call and ask. The number to
call for that is 800-835-6747.
And you can ask for the book by name.
It's called The Ultimate Resource. It's
offer number 104.
And we'll be happy to get it in the mail
and send it to you if you're in North
America. Now, if you're outside of North
America,
we encourage you to take a look at our
website, just amazingfacts.org,
and you can click on the link that says
free resources, and you can read the
book for free right there online. It's
all about the Bible and how you can
store the word of God in your heart.
When Jesus was facing temptation from
the devil, he said, "It is written. It
is written." He overcame by the word,
and that is our example.
Now, if you have a Bible-related
question, our phone line, once again, is
800-463-7297.
The phone lines are now open. And as I
mentioned a little earlier, my name is
Shawn Ross. Pastor Doug is out this
evening, but we're live, and we're ready
to take your Bible questions. We also
want to welcome those who are watching
on Amazing Facts TV, also those who are
watching on YouTube and social media.
Thank you for being a part of our
program this evening.
Our first caller this evening is
Anthony, and he's listening from New
York. Anthony, welcome to the program.
You're on Bible Answers Live.
Yes, hello, Pastor Ross. Can you hear me
okay? We can, yes.
Okay, yes. I was told that I had a
little bit of a bad connection, but um
my question, well, let me just
briefly uh explain.
Um
this uh I think it was last week,
uh after church, I got into a
conversation with um
a gentleman that was there visiting,
and um
you know, he just had some questions and
also some ideas that differed um widely
from what I believe.
But, I was, you know, I've been studying
to, you know, make sure I understand
different doctrines that I believe, and
um
uh so, I the topic about the divinity of
Christ came up. And I thought I was well
prepared. I went through Hebrews chapter
1 and um John chapter 1, verse 1, and um
uh and things like that. And then, I
used Isaiah chapter 9, verse 6.
And that's the basis of my question.
Um and it says uh
Sorry, here.
Um Sorry, I just I had it up. Uh for for
unto us a child is born, unto us a son
is given, and the government shall be
upon his shoulder, and his name shall be
called Wonderful, Counselor, the Mighty
God. And I kind of paused there for
emphasis to show that this was talking
about Jesus Christ, a prophecy of
Christ, and he's called Mighty God. And
he said, "Ah, but what about the next
part, where it says the Everlasting
Father?"
And I said, "Well, okay, yeah. So, yeah,
he's one with the Father." He's like,
"Well, that kind of defeats your point,
where you say that the Father the
Father, the Son, Jesus Christ, and the
Holy Spirit, they're three separate
beings. By him calling the Son the
Father, that defeats your point." And
so, he's like, so he thinks that it's
more symbolic, rather than that this
prophecy is symbolic, rather than
proving the divinity of Christ. So, I
guess my question is,
what why does this prophecy call Jesus
Christ the Son? Why does it also call
him the Everlasting Father? Okay, well,
very good question. Yes, the verse that
you're talking about, for those who are
maybe driving in their car, Isaiah
chapter 9, verse 6, and uh many
recognize this as a Messianic prophecy.
It's a reference to the coming Messiah.
Uh several things. Um first of all, it
does mention here that Jesus is the
Prince of Peace. And we know that when
Christ came to the earth, it was through
his sacrifice that he made peace between
the sinner and the Father, between God
and man. He is the intercessor, so we
know that refers to him. He is also
referred to as the Wonderful Counselor,
the Mighty God, so there's a reference
to Christ being divine. But, the phrase
Everlasting Father, why is that phrase
used? Well, because, especially before
the incarnation of
Christ, along with the Father, is the
source of life. John chapter 1, verse 1,
"In the beginning was the word, and the
word was with God. All things were made
by him, and without him was not anything
made that was made." So, Jesus is uh
actively involved in creation. And
seeing that he is actively involved in
creation, he is the Father of all
creation.
And so, when it's referring to Christ as
the Everlasting Father, not only was the
Father, the heavenly Father that we
think of today, involved in creation,
but Christ was also involved in the
creation of Earth. And then, of course,
when Jesus came to the earth and he was
born
here on this earth, he recognized that
his Father in heaven
was God. And of course, we have the Holy
Spirit. And Jesus baptized, you have the
Father in heaven, you have the Holy
Spirit coming upon him. Jesus is in the
water being baptized. Christ prayed to
his Father in heaven, as we need to
pray.
But, the fact that he's also referred to
as the heavenly Father indicates that he
is the creator. He is the source of
life.
And that, of course, is the same with
with God the Father we think of today in
heaven.
Does that Does that help, Anthony?
That does help. That does make sense. Um
and I'll wait till next week cuz I know
I know I can only ask one question, so
I'll
but we
this this past Sabbath someone preached
a sermon where they proved that Jesus
Christ was divine, but they said that
the Holy Spirit is not a separate
person, so but um you did help with the
one about Christ.
Yeah, that's a good question. Ask it
next week when we have a little more
time cuz that is an important one. What
role does the Holy Spirit have in the
Godhead? All right, well, thank you for
your call, Anthony. You know, we do have
a book that talks a little bit more
about the Father, Son, and the Holy
Spirit, the Godhead or the Trinity. And
the book is called The Trinity, Is It
Biblical? And we'll be happy send this
to anyone who calls and asks. Again, the
number that you need to call is
800-835-6747.
You can ask for the book, The Trinity,
Is It Biblical? What does the Bible say
about God the Father, the Son, and the
Holy Spirit. We'll be happy to send it
to anyone here in North America.
Next caller that we have is Britney
listening in California. Britney,
welcome to the program.
Hey.
Hi, and your question tonight?
Yes, my question is what does the Bible
say about flowers?
What does the Bible say about flowers?
Now, are you thinking just in general or
something specific about flowers?
Well, I'm talking about in general.
Okay. Well, there are references to
flowers in the Bible. It
Bible speaks about God creating a garden
called the Garden of Eden and all kinds
of plants were there in the garden.
There were fruit trees, there were
flowers, I'm sure, to beautify. So,
flowers is something that God created.
But in a prophetic sense, here's
something that you might not know, a
flower is actually used as a title or a
name for Jesus. And you find this in
Song of Solomon's chapter 2 verse 1.
And the flower being referred to there
is a rose and refers to the rose of
Sharon.
And here Jesus is being described as
this rose of Sharon. So, actually a
flower is used in a
in a symbolic sense in the Bible with a
reference to Jesus. So, yes, flowers are
used and spoken of in the Bible.
Next caller that we have is listening
from Colorado. We've got
Let's see, Connor listening from
Colorado. Connor, welcome to the
program. You're on the air.
Hello, how are you, Pastor I'm doing
well. Hope you're doing well, too.
Thank you, I appreciate it.
My question is
for a biblical baptism, does that have
to be done by a pastor or minister or
can that be done by someone with a good
knowledge of the word?
Well, usually when it comes to baptism,
baptism is a public profession of a
decision to follow Jesus.
And when we going to make a public
profession, we want to do so in the
company of friends and family, but also
the one leading out in that needs to be
somebody that's recognized as a leader.
For example, if two people get married,
they go to somebody who is
licensed to perform weddings, whether
that be a pastor or maybe it is a
justice of the peace, but it is somebody
that is recognized as an authority. When
we make a public profession of our faith
and we're baptized following Christ's
example, we want to do so in the
presence of family and friends, but also
we want to have someone that is
recognized as a spiritual leader. We
want to have a pastor in the church. Of
course, we want to have a pastor that
follows the Bible and Bible teaching
because I think you know there are many
different ideas out there as to what the
Bible says, so we want to make sure that
we're following
a church and we're participating with
someone who understands the Bible. But
yes, if we can, it's appropriate to have
a pastor lead out in the baptismal
service. It's It's a very special and
sacred event.
Okay.
Okay, so would that would that pertain
to like a a rebaptism, too, or is that
probably the same answer?
Well, in a rebaptism, yes, I think you'd
also want somebody because that's a re-
reaffirmation of your faith in Christ.
In some cases, if a pastor is not
available, the church elder might serve
as in that capacity. Usually though,
it's It's in communication with the
pastor. The pastor knows the elder and
maybe he's traveling or maybe the church
does not have a pastor.
That is permissible. Usually there is
some communication that takes place
between the elder of the church and
maybe the conference that is associated
with the church.
But usually you want to have somebody in
a leadership a spiritual leadership role
lead out in in the baptismal service.
Somebody that'll meet the biblical
criteria that you find
for what an elder is.
Okay, thank you. I appreciate your help.
All right, thanks for your call, Connor.
You know, we do have a book that talks
about baptism and it's called Baptism,
Is It Really Necessary? And this is our
free offer. We'll send it to anyone in
North America. All you have to do is
call the number 800-835-6747.
Ask for the book. It's called Baptism,
Is It Really Necessary? We'll send it to
you here in North America. If you're
outside of the US, again, we want to
encourage you just go to our website
amazingfacts.org
or .com and you'll be able to read it
for free right there online. We've got
Jim listening from looks like Indiana.
Jim, welcome to the program.
Yeah, the question I have is
um
in Revelation 17
10 to uh
12, yes. What are they talking about?
The the seven kings, are those political
or are they religious? Okay, great
question. Let me give a little
background to those who might not be
familiar with Revelation chapter 17. In
Revelation 17, John in vision sees a
woman and she is sitting on a
scarlet-colored beast and the beast has
seven heads
and 10 horns. Now, in Bible prophecy, a
woman represents the church and a beast
represents a political power. So, here
you have a church, a religious power
that is controlling a political power.
So, really what we have is a description
of a church and state where the state is
enforcing the decrees or the teachings
of the church. And it's really a
description of the medieval church or
the Roman Catholic Church, especially
during the Dark Ages
of papal supremacy where the papacy was
controlling the nations of Europe. There
is a revival of that at the end of time
if you keep reading in Revelation
chapter 17 Revelation chapter 13.
But the angel begins to identify these
different symbols that we find here in
Revelation. And you'll find in
Revelation 17
verse 9, it says, "Here is the mind that
has wisdom. The seven heads, that's the
seven heads of the beast, are seven
mountains on which the woman sits." So,
here we have a church that is located on
seven mountains or seven hills.
Well, of course, a church that is well
known to be situated amongst seven hills
or mountains is the church of Rome cuz
Rome is known to be the city of seven
hills.
But then it also represents something
else. And in verse 10, it says, "There
are also seven kings. Five are fallen,
one is, and one is not yet come. And
when he comes, he must continue a short
time." So, these kings, a king
represents a kingdom. These seven
kingdoms refer to seven political powers
or nations that will persecute God's
people.
And it began way back in Old Testament
times and it'll continue right up till
the very end of time just before Jesus
comes. So, the five principal nations
that warred against Israel after they
had entered into the promised land, you
have the nation of Syria or the
Assyrians that conquered the 10 tribes
of the north.
You have the nation of Babylon.
Then you have Medo-Persia. You have
Greece. And you have Rome.
So, during the 1260 years of papal
supremacy or we call that the Dark Ages,
those five powers or political powers
that are already fallen,
the one that is refers to the papacy
during its 1260-year rule cuz it says
one is and that's the description that
we find in Revelation 17.
And then it says, "One is yet to come.
And when he comes, he must continue a
short space."
Well, in Revelation chapter 13, you
discover this two beasts. The second
beast of Revelation chapter 13 is
actually the United States. And
according to Revelation 13, a time will
come when the United States will play a
leading role
in enforcing the mark of the beast. And
those who refuse to go along with these
religious laws will face persecution.
They won't be able to buy and sell. So,
the beast that is yet to come or the
political power that is yet to come in a
persecuting role is a reference there to
the United States. And then it says,
"The eighth is the beast as well." And
that again refers to the papacy. So,
those are the seven kings. Five are
fallen, one is, one is yet to come.
Those are the key players that we find
in Bible history and even right up till
the end of time.
Does that help, Jim?
Oh, yeah, that
cleared it right up. All right. Good
question. Thank you for calling.
Appreciate it.
All right, next caller that we have
Lolita is listening in Nevada. Lolita,
welcome to the program.
Hi, thank you, Pastor Ross. Yes. I'm
good to hear your voice. Thank you. My
question has to do with Jeremiah 31:15.
Um and it mentioned Rachel weeping for
her children, refusing to be comforted
for her children are gone.
Um could you explain that for me? I've
always wondered um why Rachel is
mentioned and exactly what that verse
refers to.
Okay, very good question.
It's interesting this verse that we're
finding in Jeremiah 31:15 is is actually
a prophecy because it's referred to in
Matthew chapter 2 verse 18.
And when it's referred to in Matthew
chapter 2 verse 18, it's in the context
of the decree that Herod made that all
the little baby boys in Bethlehem and in
that area was to be put to death. And
after describing this in Matthew chapter
2,
uh Matthew actually quotes Jeremiah
31:15
and he says what happened with Herod
killing the baby boys was an actual
fulfillment of this prophecy.
So, the verse verse 15 says, "A voice
was heard in Rama, lamentation, bitter
weeping, Rachel weeping for her
children." Rachel there is just a
reference to Israel and to the mothers
of Israel in particular there,
uh refusing to be comforted for her
children because they are no more.
So, her children, it's referring to
something happening to her children,
but then the promise comes, if you read
a little bit further on, it says, "But
they shall return from the land of the
enemy."
So, there is a promise, that's the next
verse.
It says, "They shall return from the
land of the enemy." There's a promise of
a resurrection.
And that was the hope that was given to
those mothers that suffered a terrible
loss of having their baby boy snatched
from their arms
and killed by um Herod in fear of a king
that would rival his throne. So, that's
Jeremiah chapter 31:15.
Does Does that help um Yes, that helped
greatly. Thank you very much. Uh that
helps a lot. Thank you.
All right. The cross-references I
mentioned there is Matthew chapter 2:18.
If you want to look up that verse and
read that as well.
We got Iran listening from New York.
Iran, welcome to the program.
Good evening, Pastor Ross. Hi. My
My question is, what was going through
the mind of Satan during the flood?
Was he scared? Was he angry or was he
laughing maniacally?
Well, you know, I we don't know for sure
what was going on in the mind of Lucifer
during the flood or Satan during the
flood, but I think one thing we realize
is that uh
Satan had never seen anything like this
before. Up until that point,
the earth was beautiful. Even after Adam
and Eve sinned and they were they were
driven from the Garden of Eden, the
earth was still a paradise. And Adam and
Eve and and their descendants lived
almost 2,000 years before the flood in
the world and then until wickedness got
so bad, the Bible says every imagination
of the heart was just evil continually.
And God said, "My spirit shall not
always strive with man. His days shall
be 120 years." And so, Noah was called
to build the ark.
Uh the devil is obviously watching as
the ark is being built and the animals
miraculously enter into the ark. Noah
and his family go into the ark. The door
in the ark is closed and then the rain
begins to come.
And it's pretty tumultuous because it
talks about the fountains of the great
deep breaking open during that time. So,
not only is the rain falling and it
hadn't rained up to that point, but you
have all this water coming down from the
sky. You also have the earth opening up
and a a massive amounts of water spewing
up through the crust of the earth
and flooding the land. And you have
volcanic activity and the whole earth is
commotion. The mountains are moving and
continents are moving. It was just a
a just something we we can't even begin
to imagine. Um and I'm sure even the
devil and his angels, which were on the
earth, witnessed all of this. I don't
know. Maybe they did experience to some
degree some fear or amazement at the
power that was demonstrated there in in
the flood. And of course, God protected
Noah and his family.
Uh that was a type of what's going to
ultimately happen to the devil and his
angels at the end of the 1,000 years.
Just like Noah and his family, they were
protected in the ark from the waters of
the flood, which purified the earth.
So, there's going to be at the end of
time a sea of fire that's going to
purify the earth. You read about this in
Revelation chapter 20.
And this fire that uh is referred to as
hell or the lake of fire, it's going to
purify the earth, but just as Noah and
his family were safe in the ark, so the
redeemed or the saved will be safe
inside the New Jerusalem.
According to Revelation chapter 21, the
New Jerusalem comes down from God out of
heaven at the end of the 1,000 years.
The wicked are resurrected for the great
white throne judgment and then they
mount their attack upon the New
Jerusalem and fire comes and devours
them.
But just as the earth was purified the
first time with water, it will be
purified the second time with fire. And
then God creates a new heavens and a new
earth wherein dwells righteousness. Now,
the devil made it through the first
purifying, that of water, but we know
the devil's not going to make it through
the second purifying, that of fire,
because the Bible says the devil and his
angels were cast into the lake of fire
and they were destroyed. So, that's kind
of a little overview. You might uh
you know, if you look at the different
cleansing and the symbols behind the
flood
and what it represents. Does that help
uh Iran a little bit?
Yeah, it helped a little bit. Yeah, you
wouldn't know what was in the mind of
Satan, but we can just imagine that it
was
pretty fearful experience for him.
Thank you.
All right. Well, thanks for call.
Again, friends, if you have a
Bible-related question, our phone lines
are open. We're going to be taking a
break here in just a few minutes, but uh
you might want to write down this
number. Our phone line here to the
studio is 800-463-7297.
So, call with your Bible question,
800-463-7297.
Also, another number that we're going to
mention from time to time, that is our
resource phone line and that number is
800-835-6747.
We have a number of free study resources
that we like to make available to
people.
And if you're listening and you're on
the road or you want to share this with
somebody else, we do have archives of
the program at the Amazing Facts
website, just amazingfacts.org.
And if you missed any of the resources
that we mentioned at the program, again,
you can visit amazingfacts.org.
Uh you can click on the Bible Answers
Live link or uh look at the various um
media that we have available and also
the free resources. And also, friends,
we want to remind you that Amazing Facts
TV is available online. So, not only do
you see that on you can see that on
Roku, but you can also see that online.
I believe it's live streaming on
YouTube. And this program is something
that we air on Amazing Facts TV every
Sunday evening. So, the number again is
800-463-7297.
The free offer that we want to encourage
you to call for tonight is the ultimate
resource. It's a book written by Pastor
Doug. We mentioned this at the beginning
of the program.
Uh it's free. All you have to do is call
800-835-6747.
It's a book written by Pastor Doug. It's
about the Bible. You might be wondering,
"How do I study the Bible?" Or, "Where
did the Bible come from?" Or, "What
about different translations or
different Bible versions?" There's a lot
of great information found in this book,
The Ultimate Resource. It's all about
the Bible and you will be blessed. Well,
again, friends, if you have a Bible
question, the number is 800-463-7297.
We are live. We will take your questions
on the air tonight. Uh we're not ending
the program by any means. We're just
coming up on a half-hour break. We don't
have time to take another call. We got
about 30 seconds left. But again, we
want to remind you, if you want to study
the Bible in more detail,
please visit amazingfacts.org.
I was just recently at the website. They
keep updating the website with uh new
information, with archived programs. Not
only this program, Bible Answers Live,
but also the Amazing Facts flagship TV
program called Amazing Facts with Doug
Batchelor is also viewable there online
at the Amazing Facts website. So, don't
go far away. We'll be back with another
half an hour of Bible Answers and we'll
take your calls live on the air. We'll
be right back in just a few moments.
[Music]
Stay tuned. Bible Answers Live will
return shortly.
[Music]
A beast, a dragon, and a woman. They
sound like characters in a fairy tale,
but that couldn't be further from the
truth.
These three symbolic end-time powers are
actually found in the book of
Revelation, whose predictions about the
soon-coming crises on earth aren't a
bedtime story.
The Beast, the Dragon, and the Woman is
a daring yet concise overview of the
Bible's most compelling and perplexing
end-time players and the struggle
between truth and error.
You'll even find out the part America
plays in these last days.
If you want to be ready for the
earth-shaking events yet to come, secure
your copy of The Beast, the Dragon, and
the Woman today. Don't be caught
unprepared for the final events of Bible
prophecy.
To order your copy of The Beast, the
Dragon, and the Woman, call 800-538-7275
[Music]
or visit afbookstore.com.
Does your heart burn for a better
purpose?
Do you yearn to do more with your faith?
Do you desire to be a powerful witness,
ablaze for Jesus Christ?
Where do you start? Make your first step
at AFCO, the Amazing Facts Center of
Evangelism. Here at AFCO, I've learned
so many things and my spiritual growth
has just skyrocketed. AFCO has distilled
50 years of Amazing Facts evangelistic
expertise into a dynamic, professional,
and educational experience that
transforms the nervous Christian into a
prepared and bold witness.
AFCO is really about learning while
doing. It's a one-of-a-kind experience
for those who are serious about entering
gospel ministry
and those who simply want to make an
impact in their local churches and
communities. Go to afco.org today and
explore this life-changing program.
AFCO, equipping soul winners, setting
the world ablaze for God.
[Music]
You're listening to Bible Answers Live,
where every question answered provides a
clearer picture of God and His plan to
save you. So, what are you waiting for?
Get
answers about the good book for a better
life today.
This broadcast is a previously recorded
episode. If you'd like answers to your
Bible-related questions on the air,
please call us next Sunday between 7:00
p.m. and 8:00 p.m. Pacific time. To
receive any of the Bible resources
mentioned in this evening's program,
call 800-835-6747.
Once again, that's 800-835-6747.
Now, let's rejoin our hosts for more
Bible Answers Live.
Hello, friends. Welcome back. This is
Bible Answers Live, a live interactive
international Bible study. We'd like to
welcome you to this program. Pastor Doug
is out this evening, but this is a live
broadcast. So, if you have Bible-related
questions, we'd love to hear from you
this evening. As we mentioned on the
break, our phone line here to the studio
is 800-46-
463- 7297. Again, that's 800-463-7297.
That'll bring you here into the studio
with your Bible question. Let's see, we
got France from California. Is it
France? Welcome to the program.
Good evening, Pastor. Good evening. And
your Bible question?
Yeah, yes. So, I just wanted you to help
me get some clarification on Daniel
this two-time prophecy at the end of
Daniel 12. Okay. And
it seems like I
try to see how you can
situate them in prophetic time. So, if
you can kind of give me a little
understanding of those two-time
prophecies, please. Sure. Revelation 12
is an interesting chapter. There's a lot
of details, but there are different time
periods. Actually, three time periods
that we read about. There's the 1260,
the 1290, and the 1335. And here we can
find it in Daniel chapter 12 verse 11.
I'm just going to read this verse. It
says, "And at that time, when the daily
sacrifice is taken away and the
abomination of desolation is set up,
there shall be 1,290
days."
Then it says, "Blessed is he that waits
and comes to the 1,335
days."
And then a little earlier, we read about
the 1335.
So, what are these different time
periods? More specifically, the 1290 and
the 1260.
Um the 1260, remember one prophetic day
is equal to one literal year in Bible
prophecy. So, the 1,260-year
time period that we read about in both
Daniel and Revelation
is the time period of papal supremacy
from 538 until 1798.
So, in 538, we have the papacy rising to
not only religious power, but more
importantly, political power.
And sort of takes the throne of the
Western Roman Empire. It rules till
1798,
where the papal power received what's
called the deadly wound, where
Napoleon's General Berthier marched into
Rome, proclaimed the political rule of
the papacy at an end, the Pope was taken
prisoner. So, that's the 1,260-year time
period. The 1,290-year time period
covers roughly the same time period, but
it begins a little earlier. It actually
begins in 508 is the starting point of
that time period.
And what's significant about that date
is that one of the actually Yeah, what's
significant about that date is one of
the political powers
that was key in
coming on board to give the papacy its
authority was France.
And in 508, you have the conversion of
Clovis, King of the Franks, that opened
up the way for full papal supremacy in
538.
So, the 1290 is referring to that time
period.
And then the 1335,
starting in 508, you go forward 1335 and
you come to the date 1843.
And what's significant about the 1843 is
the beginning of the proclamation
of the time of the end and the judgment
message that you read about in
Revelation chapter 14. So, that's just a
little bit of an overview of those
three time periods that we find in the
book of Daniel.
Does that help, Bob?
Yes, definitely, Pastor. Thank you very
much. All right. Thanks for your call.
We're going to go to Jerry in
Let's see, actually Bob in New Jersey.
Bob, welcome to the program.
My question is this. I have a friend who
is a nice little Christian guy.
He um
he he takes
he takes
communion every day by himself.
And he What he usually does, he take He
says, "You can use anything, water,
uh
water, bread, stuff like that." But what
really
what really gets me about is the fact
that I thought you were supposed to do
under the
uh under the auspices of a of a pastor
or an elder
or or or somebody to that effect. So,
but he said to me that you could do your
own
you could do your
um your your own communion because we
are the Bible says we are kings and
priests.
So, what is
what what is the the truth behind this?
Okay, good question, Bob. I'm going to
put you on on mute there. You can still
hear me. Just because we had a little
bit of feedback there in the background.
Is it possible to take communion by
yourself at home?
Uh no. You can eat by yourself at home,
and you can ask God's blessing upon your
food. There's no doubt about that.
That's good. But when it comes to
communion, communion is unique. It is a
group of believers that are gathered
together
in a worship format, and they are
together corporately
uh recognizing the sacrifice of Jesus
through the eating of the bread and the
drinking of the grape juice. Now, these
symbols are important when it comes to
communion. Jesus refers to himself as
the bread of life. And on one occasion,
Jesus said, "Whoever eats my flesh and
drinks my blood will have life in
themselves." And the people were
offended by this, and they said, "What
do you mean eat your flesh and drink
your blood?" Jesus said to them, "The
words I speak unto you, they are spirit
and they are life." So, when we partake
of the bread in communion, we're
recognizing or acknowledging that Christ
died for us. When we drink the grape
juice,
we're acknowledging that he spilled his
blood, which makes atonement for our
sins, and we are forgiven.
Now, when it comes to the bread and the
grape juice, the symbols are important.
Leaven in the Bible, or yeast as
referred to today,
uh symbolizes sin in the Bible. And so,
the bread that was used both in the
sanctuary in the Old Testament and also
the bread that's used for communion
needs to be unleavened bread, meaning
that it's free of yeast.
And when it comes to the juice, the
grape juice, it also needs to be pure
because it's a symbol of Christ's blood.
Yeast is used in the fermenting process,
so it's not an alcoholic beverage. It
needs to be fresh grape juice as a
symbol of Christ's atoning blood that
was shed. Uh the church is described as
the body of Christ. And when we gather
together corporately to worship and we
partake of communion, we together are
acknowledging that Jesus has died for
us, and we believe in him. So, communion
is not one of those ceremonies that we
are to try and do on our own, but we
want to do it as a church, a group of
believers.
Uh does that Does that help, Bob?
Well, I He says that the Bible says that
we're kings and priests.
Where does that fit in? I mean, uh Yes,
we are spiritually we are kings because
Christ is our older brother, and we are
to rule over sin, and we can be
victorious. Revelation says he who
overcomes shall inherit all things. And
we are priests in the sense of we are
sharing the gospel with others. So, we
can take the gospel, and we can share it
to somebody else. If they respond to the
gospel, well, they're also saved. But
it's got nothing to do with communion.
The idea that only a priest can offer
communion isn't biblical. Uh matter of
fact, in the New Testament, it's not You
don't read about a priesthood. It talks
about leaders in the church. You got
pastors, and you got elders, and you
have people of different responsibility.
But that's not what the verse is
referring to when it says we are kings
and priests. It's not talking about us
doing communion on our own at home.
That's a misunderstanding of the verse.
Thank you very much, Pastor. All right.
Thanks for your call, Bob. Next caller
that we have is Let's see, Jerry is
listening in Oregon. Jerry, welcome to
the program.
Good evening, Pastor Ross. My question
pertains to works. Okay.
Now, it's a core belief amongst all
Christian denominations that salvation
is a gift that cannot be earned.
Mhm. But there are some scriptures, and
I'm know that you're aware of them, but
I'll summarize them for the audience.
Um
Matthew 25, where Jesus talks about the
goats and the sheep. The The sheep are
the people who fed
um gave uh drank uh shelter and and
satisfied the needs of of those people
in need.
And uh the the goats are the ones who
didn't do that. The goats are on his
left side. Then he says
at the in there
then he will say to those on his left,
the goats, those who didn't do the good
deeds, "Depart from me, you who are
cursed, into the eternal fire prepared
for the devil and the angels. For I was
hungry, you gave me nothing to eat,
etc."
And so on. And then
then in Revelation 20,
it says
uh towards the DC verse
um 12 or so, uh
or 13,
"The dead were judged according to what
they had done, as recorded in the books.
The sea gave up the dead that were in
it,
and death and Hades gave up the dead
that were in them and each person was
judged according to what they had done.
Mhm.
Then death and Hades were thrown into
the lake of fire. The lake of fire is
the second death. Anyone who whose name
was not found written in the book of
life was thrown into the lake of fire.
So I would infer from that the saved are
in the book of life, but they're being
judged by their works.
Okay, great question. Yeah, let me see
if I can shed
light on that. So we saved by faith. We
actually saved by grace through faith.
How do we obtain the grace? It's through
faith. Not of works as Paul says in
Romans lest we shall be judged. But the
kind of faith that saves us is a faith
that works.
So if we claim to have faith, but our
faith is not working meaning our lives
are not changing,
then that means the kind of faith that
we have is a counterfeit faith.
A genuine faith will be revealed in what
we do. That's why when it comes to the
judgment God could actually look at our
works and our works will tell whether or
not we have genuine faith. Now that's a
faith that saves us,
but our works will testify as to what
kind of faith we have. That's why James
tells us if you go look in the book of
James,
it says some will say, "Well, I have
faith."
Uh but I don't have works. He says
somebody else might say, "Well, I have
faith and it's revealed by my works."
So true faith will always be revealed in
obedience, uh willing obedience.
Shadrach, Meshach, and Abednego when
they stood on the plain of Dura and a
death decree was given anyone who would
not bow down and worship the golden
image. Oh well, they were saved by
faith. They were trusting in God, but
that faith demonstrated itself in works.
They stood faithful when everyone else
bowed down.
So uh true faith will always be
demonstrated by works of obedience uh
reflecting the character of God. Does um
Does that help, Jerry?
Yes, and there was another scripture.
Faith without works is dead.
Correct.
So any Christian who claims he's saved
by
the sacrifice of Jesus and does not do
help his fellow man, etc., is
is not a genuine Christian.
It's It's the wrong kind of faith,
right? And it's possible even to deceive
yourself thinking that you have faith,
but if your faith is not producing uh
kind works, well then that's the wrong
kind of faith. And of course this faith
comes from God. Uh it's a gift. We can
ask for it, but we need to exercise that
faith in doing those things that are
pleasing to him. Good question, Jerry.
Thank you for your call. Next caller
that we have is Tyvision listening in
Illinois. Tyvision, welcome to the
program.
Tyvision, that's a new one.
You know, that's what popped up on my
screen. What is your name?
Up, we might have missed him. Let's try
here.
Dina, Dina New York, are you there?
Yes, sir, I am.
All right. Okay, I think we're through.
And your question tonight?
My question is um hold on, let me turn
this down. Um
I'm sorry, I'm driving, so I really
can't
ex- exactly tell you
uh where it is that I read it, but I
know it's in the book of Genesis where
it says that um
and God put Adam in the garden.
Yes.
Uh so I to know was he created in the
It seems like he was not created in the
garden.
He created Eve from Adam in the garden.
But from what I heard it says and God
put Adam in the garden. Okay. Yeah, let
me just refer to the verse. I think the
one you're referring to is Genesis
chapter 2 verse 8. And it says, "The
Lord God planted a garden eastward of
Eden and there he put the man whom he
had formed." So your idea is was was
Adam created outside the garden or was
he created inside the garden? Um
That's what it sounds like because he
put him there.
Yes. Now the phrasing that you have
here, and I'm looking from This is the
New King James. Some other translations
might explain a little bit clearer. The
idea of being put in the garden isn't
necessarily picking something up and
putting it in a different place. Rather
it carries with it the idea that that's
their home. That That's their dwelling
place. So the garden became the home of
Adam and Eve. Um most likely God created
the garden first and then he formed Adam
and gave him the garden as his home.
That became his his dwelling place. The
whole earth was before him, but
specifically the garden was his home or
his dwelling place. So the Bible doesn't
tell us for sure, you know, if God
created Adam right at the gate and kind
of let him into the garden. It could
very well have been the case. Or if he
was created in the garden and God said
this garden is yours in the sense of
putting him in the garden. The Bible's
not exactly clear on that.
But either way I think the idea would be
there that the garden became their home.
Uh-huh.
We've been taught all our lives that
they were, you know, they were created
in the garden and all that. And I was
reading and I said, "Wait a minute, he
put him there." Yes. So
Put him there in the sense of that was
his home, his dwelling place.
Mhm. And thank you guys so much. Uh
about 10 years ago Pastor Doug sent me a
booklet that was talking about the uh
the chip. And it was like it was going
to be in in in something that looked
like a little grain of rice.
And uh all our information was going to
be put there and then under our skin.
And I was telling people it's like,
"Well, this is what's going to happen."
And people were looking at me like I was
crazy. And that's exactly what is
happening now. Yes, uh when you get into
Bible prophecy you learn some
interesting things. And of course I
wouldn't be the first one to want to get
any kind of implant under the skin and
the Bible speaks against that. But from
a spiritual sense, when you talk about
the mark of the beast, we understand it
has to do with worship. It's not a
physical computer chip, but it really
has to do with worship and allegiance.
Who do we obey and who do we worship?
Matter of fact, we do have a study guide
that talks about that for anyone wanting
to learn more about the mark of the
beast. Is it a computer chip in the hand
or in the forehead? Or what does the
Bible say about that? And I think um
Dina referenced uh that subject. You can
read the study guide. It's called The
Mark of the Beast. And all you have to
do is call and ask for it. The number is
800-835-6747.
And again, just ask for the study guide.
It's called The Mark of the Beast. We're
going to try uh Illinois once again. I
Tyvision, I I'm not pronouncing your
name right.
No, it's uh Tavion. Tavion, thank you.
All right. And your question this
evening?
Yes, my uh question was um
so it's like I was going through the
Bible um cuz I like read through the uh
New Testament uh already and I'm uh
going through the Old. And um
and I was brought back to I believe it
was Matthew 12:42.
Yeah, 42. About the Queen of the South
how she shall rise in the judgment and
uh the the how she shall rise and
generally condemn uh the generation.
Mhm. So So I've taken that as especially
due to the fact that it put Solomon in
there that it's confirming that the
Queen of Sheba
will be in heaven. But I also read, I
think it was one of the other gospels or
maybe it was someone in the New
Testament that it also confirmed that
King Nebuchadnezzar was going to be
there, too.
Yes, that that's a good point. We
believe Nebuchadnezzar will be here
because he actually wrote a chapter in
the Bible. It's the only chapter that we
know of written by a pagan king and you
find it in the book of Daniel.
Yes, Daniel 4 is actually the
description of Nebuchadnezzar's dream
and the explanation of the dream. And
then at the end of the chapter you read
how that Nebuchadnezzar acknowledges the
God of heaven worships him. So the fact
that there is a chapter recorded by
Nebuchadnezzar in the Bible and that at
the end of the chapter he acknowledges
and worships the God of heaven is a
strong indication that yes, he was
saved. He did come to a knowledge of the
true God.
Okay. Okay, I just wanted to make sure
because like I was going through um
Matthew and then like I got confused
because I'm like, "Okay, I know we
believe that he's going to heaven." But
I thought there was a specific verse
that said that he would go into heaven
along with the Queen of Sheba before the
Pharisees.
Not in the New Testament, no. Uh
the evidence used for Nebuchadnezzar
being saved comes directly from Daniel.
Okay, thank you. All right, great
question. Thank you. Next caller that we
have is Raymond listening from Michigan.
Raymond, welcome to the program.
Hello, sir. How you doing? Doing well,
thank you.
And your question tonight?
My question is is in Genesis 4 chapter
14. Okay.
Uh after um God cursed Cain for killing
Abel, surely you have driven me out
this day from the face of the ground. I
shall be hidden from your face. I shall
be a fugitive and a vagabond Yes.
on the earth. And it will happen
that anyone who finds me will kill me.
Yes. How could he How could he have said
that when there was only Adam and Eve
and himself on the earth? Okay, by the
time this story occurred between Cain
and Abel,
uh there were other sons and daughters
born to Adam and Eve that are not
referenced specifically at the time
because you read
Sorry, you read on later on it talks
about Adam and Eve Adam and Eve having
other sons and daughters.
So, where did Cain and Abel, or at least
Cain, where did Cain get his wife? Well,
it was a sister. It was a daughter of
Adam and Eve. So, there were other
people on the earth. How many? The Bible
does not tell us.
But, the fact that, you know, they were
all related and they were all siblings,
you can understand Cain's concern if one
of his brothers come across him and they
know that he killed Abel,
well, maybe they'll want to kill him.
So, it it would be the other siblings of
of Cain. That's being referred to there.
Okay. Okay.
All right.
Thank you very much and you all are
doing a great job
All right.
on the radio. Thanks for your call,
Raymond. Appreciate it. Okay. Okay,
thank you.
Next caller that we have, let's see.
We've got um
Robert listening in Washington. Robert,
welcome to the program.
Uh hello. Thank you for taking my call,
Pastor Ross. Hi. And your question
tonight?
I thought I'd ask you a revelation
question since that's your specialty. I
like revelation, yes.
Um
The one guy a few couple or three three
uh things ago was mentioning the
question that I asked or at least you
were you breezed through it anyway
about death and hell or he said Hades.
Yes.
But, um
I've heard of that heard of it saying, I
guess that's probably the King James
uh death and hell being cast into the
lake of fire. How can hell be cast into
itself kind of thing? Oh, good question.
All right, the verse I think you're
referring to, I'm just going to put you
on mute there cuz we had a little
background noise.
Revelation chapter 20 and it's verse 14.
Actually, starting verse 13.
It says, "The sea gave up the dead that
was in it and death and Hades delivered
up the dead that were in them, and they
were judged each according to their
works." Now, the word Hades there simply
means the grave. This is the old King
James language. I'm using the new King
James. So, when it says death and Hades,
it just simply means death and the grave
were delivered up. And then verse 14
says, "And death and Hades," same word,
talking about the grave, "death and
Hades were cast into the lake of fire.
This is the second death." Meaning that
after
the lake of fire does its work, there
will be no more death and there will be
there'll be no more grave.
So, sometimes in King James, you find
the word hell used for the grave, but it
just simply means the grave. It's not a
place of torment.
That was a pagan idea that came along
later on, but the word
Hades just means the grave. So, that's
the explanation there. Does that Does
that help, Robert?
Yes, thank you very much. Okay, you're
welcome. Thanks for your call.
I think we have call time for maybe,
let's see. We got
one more caller perhaps.
Lilia listening from Arizona. We got
about 2 minutes, Lilia.
Hello, thank you. Um during the 7-year
tribulation, will no one be able to be
saved? Is it too Even if they repent?
Okay. Well, first of all, you know, you
mentioned the word 7 years of
tribulation. You won't find 7-year
tribulation in the Bible. Uh there is a
tribulation that the Bible speaks about,
but it's not going to be 7 years. During
the tribulation, the seven last plagues
get poured out. Maybe that's where the
confusion is. Sometimes people think the
seven last plagues and they think of
that as being 7 years.
But, actually, the seven last plagues
will fall roughly in about the period of
a year. And the reason we say that is
because Revelation speaks of the plagues
coming upon Babylon in 1 day.
One prophetic day is equal to 1 literal
year. So, you have a time of trouble or
you call it the tribulation. It's about
the period of a year when the seven last
plagues are poured out. Now, it is true
that before the the seven last plagues
are poured out, probation does close.
So, there'll be two groups when that
time comes. Those who have the seal of
God, those who love God and keep his
commandments, and those who have the
mark of the beast. And then probation
closes, the seven last plagues are
poured out, but the plagues don't harm
those who have the seal of God. They're
protected during this time of widespread
destruction.
They're protected because they're sealed
by God. And then at the end of that
tribulation, then Jesus comes and you
have the great resurrection, the dead in
Christ are resurrected, those who are
alive are caught up to meet Jesus in the
air.
And the wicked are destroyed with the
brightness of his coming.
So, when this great tribulation spoken
of in Daniel chapter 12, when that time
does come, probation would have closed.
Everybody would have made up their mind
which side they're going to be on. But,
that tribulation is not closed yet. The
gospel is still going out to the world.
People are still responding. The Holy
Spirit is speaking to the hearts of
individuals. Probation is not yet
closed. But, when it does close, after
the mark of the beast becomes an issue
and you have the seal of God, then it is
that everyone's made up their mind.
Probation closes and the seven last
plagues are poured out. You know, we do
have a study guide that talks about the
mark of the beast and it's called the
mark of the beast and we'll be happy to
send it to anyone who calls and asks.
The number is 800-835-6747.
And you'll have a lot more information
more than I can actually share on the
radio
with all the Bible verses and everything
related to the subject of the mark of
the beast or the seal of God. Now,
friends, you hear that
music in the background, we got two more
minutes of internet questions. So, don't
go too far. We just want to say goodbye
to some of the radio stations turning
off, but stay by, we'll be right back.
[Music]
Thank you for listening to today's
broadcast. We hope you understand your
Bible even better than before. Bible
Answers Live is produced by Amazing
Facts International, a faith-based
ministry located in Granite Bay,
California.
Hello, friends. Welcome back. We got
about 2 minutes before we actually sign
off from our program. We want to thank
those who sent in their internet
questions. If you have a Bible question
you'd like to email us, you just simply
email the address
balquestions@amazingfacts.org.
That's balquestions@amazingfacts.org.
And we will try to answer as many of
these questions as we could or can in
the next minute and a half. So, we do
have some questions that came in.
First question is, did the angels know
what was good and evil before Eve
committed sin?
Revelation chapter 12 talks about a war
in heaven where Michael and his angels
fought against the dragon.
And the dragon and his angels, they lost
the war and they were thrown out of
heaven. So, there was a knowledge of
right and wrong prior to Adam and Eve.
And of course, the devil tempted Adam
and Eve or Eve and then Eve gave the
fruit to Adam. He knew what he was
doing. He knew that he was trying to get
them to disobey God and disobey his
commandments.
Another question that we have, does the
Bible say that some people are saved in
the second resurrection?
Well, the Bible speaks of two general
resurrections. There is the first
resurrection that takes place at the
second coming of Christ when the dead in
Christ are resurrected. And then they go
to heaven for a thousand years.
At the end of the thousand years in
Revelation chapter 21, you have the New
Jerusalem coming down from heaven.
At that time, Jesus sets his feet on the
Mount of Olives and it opens up and
forms a great valley and the New
Jerusalem comes to rest. And then all
the wicked are resurrected. They're
resurrected for the great white throne
judgment. You read about in Revelation
chapter 20, at the end of which the
wicked mount their attack upon the New
Jerusalem and fire comes down and
devours them. So, those resurrected in
the second resurrection, is there any
hope of them being converted and saved?
The answer is no.
Those who are resurrected in the first
resurrection, they're the ones that are
saved. Those who are resurrected in the
second resurrection, they're the ones
who are in rebellion against God.
They're resurrected simply for the final
judgment. And then their destruction
comes.
Our last question that we're going to be
able to get, is the Holy Spirit on the
left hand of God the Father if Jesus is
seated at the right hand of God the
Father? Well, it's interesting when you
look in Revelation chapter 4, you have a
description of the heavenly throne room
and it speaks about God seated upon his
throne, but before the throne, in front
of the throne, it talks about seven
burning lamps of fire, which is a symbol
of the Holy Spirit. So, we know Christ
is at the right hand of the Father, the
Holy Spirit has a position at least
described in Revelation chapter 4 as
being before the throne, not necessarily
on the other side of the throne. So,
that is an interesting point. Thank you
for calling in, friends. We look forward
to next week for more Bible Answers
Live.
[Music]